as I said before we began rolling we
have a lot of screenwriters who watch
our Channel
I'm wondering if you can talk about how
you and your writing partner Jason ended
up getting signed with an agency oh good
question so we were bashing each other's
screenplays we were roommates in New
York we were slumming in Queens we were
23 years old 24 and we were critiquing
each other's scripts and then we decided
well we just write one together and we
wrote this movie was called Sydney Hall
not the vanishing in Sydney all the time
and we were interested in this idea of
how how different we were when we were
18 and now we're 24 and we felt like you
know we had changed a lot and not
necessarily matured not necessarily a
better person and we wanted to write
something that it reflected that so we
wrote Sydney Hall we wrote it in I don't
know a half year or so and we emailed it
back and forth to each other and then a
friend of mine Paul Wesley
had a manager and he gave it to manager
and she gave it to at that time yeah WME
and w and me an agent over there read it
and really loved didn't signed us and
that's really how it was so I had an
actor friend essentially who had a
manager and really it's Paul Wesley's
fault
that I am in this industry because he
did that and he also is good with notes
and
to help me with other giving me notes on
some my other screenplays but uh I think
for an aspiring screenwriter unsolicited
scripts is the problem right you know
you you know finding out who to give it
to or or anything like that I think you
know people in in the film industry the
film industry is completely and wholly
based on relationships and knowing
people and you don't have to know that
the big stars or the big managers or
anything like that but I think any
aspiring screenwriter if they know
someone who plays bit parts on a show or
something like that and that person is a
manager an agent I'd say that's the good
route to go the way we did it which is
you know see if they like your script
and maybe give it to them and see and
get it so that you know a screenplay
coming from
if the screenplay goes to someone of
importance who can pay pay you rewrite
it or pay for it to be made or or make
it into a movie and you know someone who
knows someone that is friends with them
they'll read it if it comes from a
friend as opposed to if it's submitted
just you know out of the blue from
nowhere you know
you